[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui judith
et non l'une des commissaires de
l'exposition quartiers et les arts de
l'islam qui se tient au musée des arts
décoratifs jusqu'au 20 février
fabrice gaignault pour son roman la vie
la plus douce et benoît doremus qui sort
son cinquième album désolé pour les
fantômes et l'on commence comme toujours
pas les images que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque la vôtre
benoît lavoie si
je crois voir ce quoi il s'agit mais
préciser quand même on voit beaucoup de
choses justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi parce que pour résumer notre
époque gelé quelque chose qui englobe un
peu cette can le diront qu'on voit un
petit bull iss à gauche tant que c'est
une photo prise par thomas pesquet well
as alors il faut bien regarder c'est
tout en bas à gauche qui a effectivement
dit pas non en métal voilà c'est dit sgt
j'ai suivi de près ce qui est tout ce qu
il a dit je continue d'écouter vos
chansons devant rossi m'a fait ce petit
cadeau me fait un petit clin d'oeil de
la hook était incroyable je le suivais
avant ça et puis cette photo pour moi
résume beaucoup de choses on y voit là
la fragilité de la terre évidemment que
le climat qui nous affole tous et puis à
la fois je trouvais que ça renvoie vers
la maîtrise de l'humanité avec la
technologie incroyable et le progrès
avec une majuscule et et puis je
trouvais j'ai choisi aussi parce que ça
m'évoque le recul dont on manque souvent
et je l'envié un petit peu thomas
pesquet d'être là où est d'avoir cette
vision d'ensemble sur cette petite bulle
de savon dans laquelle on vit et voilà
moi c'est un recul que j'ai pas du tout
au quotidien je l'envié pour ça fabrice
gaignault votre photo à vous alors moi
je
faisais des photos à moins que je me
sois trompé de l'époque
votre époque où cette réduction de 70
donc ça c'est laisser oui ces pompes lon
donc la grande plage de saint tropez
dans les années soixante dix apparemment
ce que je peux voir de près les bat c et
c'est un des personnages si j'ose dire
ça c'est un une situation assez
importante dans livres puisque c'est un
lieu où va se
où le personnage va va découvrir l'amour
dans les bras d'une jeune fille de son
âge et puis c'est l'époque aussi que je
dépeins sur les seins nus qui sont pas
très nul à nantes
c'était l'époque des seins nus sur la
plage et de l'espèce d'exubérance des
années soixante dix avec les avantages
et les inconvénients et défauts et il
reviendra en effet et sur saint tropez
et sur les années 60 70 tout à l'heure
vous gênez de la photo
alors je vois qu'il ya de l'art
islamique en bas c'est une vue de d'une
des expositions qui ont lieu en ce
moment dans 18 villes en france consacré
aux arts de l'islam qui s'appelle un
passé pour un présente une vue de
l'exposition figeac et pour moi cela
illustre vraiment l'envié j'irai le
besoin de culture qu'on a en ce moment
après ces longs mois sans musée
et le public est au rendez-vous en fait
c'est un vrai succès populaire et bien
commençons
[Musique]
judith et non vous êtes directrice
adjointe au département des arts de
l'islam mahomet musée du louvre et vous
êtes l'une des commissaires de
l'exposition quartiers et les arts de
l'islam qui se tient jusqu'au 20 février
au musée des arts décoratifs à paris
alors il faut d'abord comprendre que
paris au tout début du 20e siècle c'est
la plaque tournante du commerce
des arts islamiques tout à fait pourquoi
pourquoi il ya plusieurs raisons
effectivement
la langue française l'implantation
[Musique]
des français dans des villes comme le
caire comme istanbul qui sont des lieux
importants pour le commerce de l'art
islamique et c'est surtout le lieu où
vont se tenir de grandes expositions
à paris parly pardon et donc
effectivement ce n'est pas la seule on à
londres aussi qui attire un certain
nombre d'oeuvres mais paris c'est
vraiment le lieu si on veut constituer à
cette époque une collection d'art
islamique ouais vous dites à un moment
dans le dans le catalogue qu' il ya des
types qui viennent en iran chercher du
lait qui il trouve rien on leur dit mais
c'est déjà parti à paris
voyageurs qui reviennent bredouilles dix
ans mais en fait les marchands et
notamment les marchands arménien puisque
ce sont eux qui s'empare notamment de ce
commerce de l'art islamique sur place en
iran les marchands arméniens ont envoyé
toutes les pièces de qualité déjà à
paris donc en fait sur place on trouve
plus rien et
c'est le moment où on reconnaît que ça
fait partie de l'histoire de l'art parce
que les occidentaux ont toujours été à
ses gènes ou dans ce domaine les
américains sont rentrés dans l'histoire
de l'art quasiment dans les années 60
avant vannes on le depping apple un peu
avant mais mais avant la seconde guerre
mondiale il n'y a que les français les
anglais les italiens les espagnols dans
l'histoire de l'art y a personne d'autre
en fait c'est vraiment au début de ce
xxème siècle qu'on a un petit courant de
d'amateurs qui vont essayer de faire
émerger les arts de l'islam comme une
discipline scientifique à travers des
expositions et la plus marquante est
certainement celle qui est organisée à
munich en 1910 et qui est la première à
présenter des oeuvres d'art islamique
sans accumulation sans décor où il ya
une vraie rupture avec l'orientalisme
des expositions précédentes et là on a
des oeuvres qui sont de très belles
qualités qui sont présentés sans décor
pour leurs qualités propres et c'est
vraiment ce à cette date qu'on peut dire
qu'on a que colis que les arts de
l'islam rentrer dans l'histoire de l'art
véritablement et ça va déclencher des
passions et notamment chez louis cartier
le poil à la tête de la maison cartier
mais reste haut sur les arts de l'islam
vous dites également
au fond ça amplifie l'idée qu'on a à ce
moment là de la décadence de l'art
occidental
oui tout à fait en est on a l'impression
qu'on est en décadence alors que pour
nous rétrospectivement on se dit que
c'est une époque extraordinaire artiste
et alors on est dans des époques
historiciste ou m'ont copiée les
périodes précédentes les périodes
antérieures et
on a l'impression qu'on est à bout de
souffle et con con qu'on est à court
d'inspiration et en fait ces amateurs
justement qu'ils vont utiliser l'aris la
faim vont utiliser l'art islamique pour
essayer de donner un nouveau souffle à
la création et pour fournir de nouveaux
modèles aux artistes et ça va marcher
oui ça va influencer les artistes ça va
influencer la décoration ça va
influencer la mode zombie s'habille ça
va influencer la joaillerie notamment à
travers quartier les objets de luxe pas
seulement les bijoux et un quartier fait
aussi des objets nuque ddd des boîtes de
cigarettes cédera tout ça va être on va
le voir en train daris lamic mais est-ce
que les gens qui les achètent est-ce que
les gens à ce moment là qui s'habille de
cette façon est ce qu'ils sont confiants
alors pas toujours en tout cas pour les
bijoux de chez cartier je ne pense pas
alors il ya c'est la grande époque où on
fait des bals costumés on s'habille ont
fait le bal des milieux de la mi lé
deuxième nuit donc là oui bien
évidemment qu'on est conscient
dans les décors aussi c'est l'époque des
ballets russes qui vont jouer à paris
pour la première fois donc et on joue
sherazade voilà donc là effectivement on
est conscient après je dois dire que
cela par exemple quand on voit ces
objets pas ce qui ressort de cette de
l'analyse en tout cas qu'on a faim de de
cette recherche dont l'exposition et le
résultat c'est que très probablement
les formes utilisées notamment par la
maison cartier sont tellement intégrée
qui a pas forcément une conscience que
ces objets sont inspirés par les arts de
l'islam oui c'est ça
c'est il ya parfois même de pure copie
parfois on est très proche du modèle et
d'autres fois on est très éloigné dire
que eux
c'est notamment grâce au dessin vous
montrer les dessins ce sont les dessins
qui nous ont permis parfois de de
prouver notre hypothèse de départ parce
que initialement on se disait voilà
est-ce que c est ce que ce sont les uns
et cela mais est-ce que c'est pas l'asie
est ce que est ce qu'on se trompe pas en
faisant le lien entre
une mosaïque et alors là là c'est plus
évident mais parfois ça l'était moins et
effectivement grâce au dessin on a pu
reconstituer tout le processus créatif
et parfois apporter la preuve que la
source d'inspiration c'était bien une
pièce d'art islamique et est ce qu'on
s'en inspire
par nostalgie un peu comme fabrice
gaignault s'inspire des années 60 et il
n'est pas le seul en étant une grande
époque de d'ostalgie aujourd'hui en
france est ce que c'est de la nostalgie
pas du tout parce qu'en fait il faut
avoir en tête qu'à l'époque on ne voyage
pas aussi facilement qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a pas accès à ces oeuvres est que
justement la découverte de ses oeuvres à
travers le marché de l'art parisien
constitue un vrai véritable choc
esthétique et notamment pour les
artistes on découvre les arts de l'islam
pour la première fois mais ça pouvait
pardon je voulais dire par nostalgie
dans le sens où il ya une préciosité il
ya des matériaux qu'on est peut-être à
ce moment là en train de perdre déjà
non je dirais pas vraiment par nostalgie
est qu'on est vraiment dans quelque
chose de complètement nouveau et
complètement innovant et vous dites
d'ailleurs c'est le sous titre de
l'exposition aux sources de la mort de
la modernité tout à fait parce qu'en
fait on se rend compte en étudiant le
vocabulaire de la maison cartier que
cette inspiration qu'ils vont puiser
dans les arts de l'islam et notamment
dans les formes géométriques parce qu'à
l'époque on ne dans la bijouterie on ne
trouve pas beaucoup de formes
géométriques
on est plutôt en tout cas chez cartier
dans le style guirlandes c'est à dire on
s'inspire des enroulements végétaux des
ferronneries du xviiie des pompons des
noeuds ils vont trouver dans l'art
islamique des formes assez pur
assez éthérée qu'ils vont employer et on
peut on peut on peut dire que grâce aux
arts de l'islam ils vont amorcer les
prémices de l'art déco tout en sautant
la période de l'art nouveau ils ne font
pas du tout d'un nouveau et ils vont
passer de ce style guirlandes un petit
peu
monde ya un petit peu chargé à ses
formes géométriques qui vont amorcer
l'art déco et donc ils vont rentrer dans
une certaine modernité à travers ses
inspirations islamique il ya l'inde
aussi qui va avoir beaucoup d' influence
sur la maison cartier mais à partir des
années 20-30 plus tôt
de manière antérieures parce qu'en fait
qu'on a ce qu'on a démontré dans
l'exposition c'est tout à fait très tôt
la maison va s'intéresser à l'inde
ils vont envoyer les frères quartier
vont envoyer jacques le plus jeune frère
en 1 de faire un très grand voyage pour
nous est de
des liens étroits avec la clientèle des
maharadjahs mais pas uniquement
également pour trouver des sources
d'approvisionnement en pierres
précieuses et en perles parce qu'il sera
ensuite à bahreïn et il va rapporter
dans ses valises de nombreux bijoux
indiens que la maison va vendre parfois
tel quel donc ils vont faire plusieurs
expositions à londres à paris à boston à
new york où ils vont vendre des bijoux
indiens et ensuite on voit qu'ils vont
les modifier les transformer c'est le
cas voilà tout appareil ou ses
magnifiques sonné oui c'est vraiment
magnifique là on est devant un le
collier d'un grand col et le bracelet
d'un grand collectionneur d'art
islamique qui s'appelle search hester
betty dont la bibliothèque est
aujourd'hui à dublin avec les celui
d'une collection tout à fait alors
certes schefter betty amène les pierres
que vous voyez qui sont des amulettes
iranienne il amène les pierres et
quartier va réaliser ce bracelet qui est
inspirée d'un modèle qu'il trouve dans
un ouvrage qui est consacré aux bijoux
indiens qui est écrit par soir thomas
cinglé et on a le livre dans la
bibliothèque
de la maison qui était arrive qu'ils
étaient accessibles aux dessinateurs et
on fait le lien du coup entre cette
inspiration de cet ouvrage le bracelet
qui elle réalise avec des pierres
iranienne
et adrian wills fabrice gaignault
boucherie qui est un petit côté mondrian
oui mais c'est vraiment la barre des
redites et géométriques elle et elle est
au sol et vous montrait bien en fait
dans cette exposition tout le côté
géométriques je voulais qu'on trouve
très moderne et très occidentale en fait
elle vient de là
est d'ailleurs une question que j'avais
envie de vous poser on parle beaucoup d'
islam en france depuis quelques années
je pense qu'on en a jamais autant parlé
vous en tant que spécialiste des arts
islamiques est ce que vous y
reconnaissez est ce que les discussions
les débats qui peuvent y avoir avoir
lieu sur l'islam ont un rapport avec
l'islam que vous connaissez vous non
parce que nous vraiment on traite de la
civilisation islamique c'est vrai qu'on
fait parfois le mélange quand on parle
d'art de l'islam on parle des arts qui
se sont développées dans la civilisation
islamique du du milieu du 7e siècle
jusqu'au 19ème siècle et qui sont
d'ailleurs
produite enfin le la civilisation
islamique qu elle s est une mosaïque de
peuples c'est une mosaïque de langues
c'est une mosaïque de religion mais ce
n'est pas un art uniquement religieux
bien sûr qu'on a des pièces qui sont
réalisés à destination de deux mosquées
de monuments religieux mais pas
uniquement on a beaucoup d'objets de
luxe produits pour des élites urbaines
des objets du quotidien aussi et quand
on dit que il n'y a pas de
représentation du visage dans les arts
islamiques c'est vrai regardez les
photos qui défilent derrière nous
desservir au tout premier tableau du
tabac a frappé quand j'ai vu les
premiers tableaux figuration
effectivement il est interdit sur une
interdiction de la figuration dans la
lah on envoie comptant les lieux
religieux mais je dirais c'est une
civilisation du livre on est on connaît
énormément manuscrits énormément de
peinture ce sont ces peintures justement
là vous avez des peintures qui
proviennent de la collection louis
cartier sa collection personnelle qu'il
constitue justement après avoir
découvert l'exposition de munich et fait
notable c'est que cette collection il va
la mettre à disposition de ces
dessinateurs pour les inspirer par ton
jeu mais je m'éloigne un petit peu et
donc vous voyez que c'est bien sûr une
civilisation aussi de l'image on a
énormément d'image mais le contexte
voilà là on est dans un manuscrit dans
quelque chose qu'on regarde de manière
intime
quand on l'a dit l' influence que ça va
avoir sur sur une certaine modernité est
évidente ça va avoir de l'influencé sur
tous les noirs à nous c'est à dire sur
le cinéma vous avez retrouvé des traces
à peu près dans tous alors en tout cas
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a pu démontrer moi
c'est que j'ai été surprise de voir
l'ampleur que ça avait à l'époque en
dépouillant notamment des magazines de
mode des années 10 il y avait un
véritable une irano feeling incroyable
c'était la mode persane et sa infuse
toutes les couches de la société c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas réservé à une
élite là on est face à des costumes de
poire est effectivement là on est pour
de la très haute bourgeoisie mais même
madame tout le monde si je puis dire
pouvait avoir son son son sweat
à la mode personnes et on le retrouve
très bien dans la presse de l'époque
c'est incroyable d'appeler ça à sweet l
époque un sweeter twitter pour la maison
et suit déjà des noms commencent à
s'angliciser déjà tout début du 20e
siècle en fait les bois anglais date de
la ca c les décors aussi
ça aussi on s'en aperçoit les décors
soient imprégnés de deux d'art islamique
enfin on appelle ça l'art musulman à
l'époque l'art musulman à saâles eux le
nom évolue effectivement on parle d'art
musulmans ont pas aussi d'art mahométans
mais en tout cas oui on retrouve on
retrouve cette influence à la fois comme
vous l'avez dit dans le divertissement
dans le spectacle beaucoup dans la mode
dans la décoration d'intérieur parce
qu'on connaît des papiers peints
notamment qui sont inspirés de ces
miniatures persanes et donc ça c'est
vraiment liée à l'arrivée massive en
fait entre les années 1900 cissé 1911 de
peinture et de manuscrits du monde
indiens iraniens qui vont arriver sur le
marché de manière très importante
parce que l'iran à cette époque là est
confrontée à la révolution
constitutionnelle et que du coup de
nombreuses oeuvres sortent du territoire
à ce moment-là et des oeuvres de très
grande qualité oui donc à chantonnay
voulait dire elles sont pas forcément il
y en a qui sont volés et aussi des
collections privées qui profitent de
cette période un petit peu mouvementée
pour en habiller la même chose au moment
de l'invasion de l'irak par les
américains que énormément de pièces
avaient disparu en irak qu elle avait
été revendue est-ce qu'on commence à les
revoir
vous devez être attentif quand on voit
des nouvelles pièces arrivée est ce que
est ce qu'il y en a qui pourraient
provenir des musées irakiens qui ont été
payées à l'époque on fait toujours
extrêmement attention surveille le
marché il ya des équipes qui sont dédiés
à cette recherche de manière enfin à
plein de temps si je puis dire c'est à
dire que moi c'est pas véritablement
dans
l'ancien en mai mission moi je suis moi
je suis plus sur le monde iranien mais
oui à cette époque pour revenir à la
question de la révolution
constitutionnelle où il ya des oeuvres
qui ont été volées elles sont
identifiées on sait qu'à cette époque
elle sorti illégalement du territoire
iranien et sont des pièces qui
proviennent des bibliothèques royal
est ce qu'il ya des pièces à ce moment
là que si on vit au début du 20e siècle
les français sont présents d'algérie
est ce qu'il ya des pièces qui viennent
du maghreb à ce moment-là et thoune
amant il y en a c'est peu et ça c'est
probablement lié dont je vous parlais de
cette collection louis cartier qui est
qui va influencer directement la
création de la maison louis en fait à
véritablement à un goût très marqué pour
l'iran et l'inde et ça on le voit très
clairement dans les objets qu'il va
collecter c'est un grand bibliophile
donc sa collection d'art islamique elle
révèle aussi cette passion qu'il a pour
les livres dont on trouve beaucoup de
manuscrits beaucoup de peinture est
également des objets incrustés très
précieux et là je dois dire ces petites
déformations professionnelles
probablement voilà vous avez montré tout
à l'heure les très beaux plus rien en
ivoire qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
collections du musée du louvre et le
public du chat d'ailleurs ils fiables
les plumiers du chien tout à fait mais
ça par exemple pardon c'est c'est fou ça
se voit tout de suite pour moi que ça
bien voir et sur l'inde très clairement
et dont je vous parlais de cette
pratique de la maison de
de reconstruire des bijoux à partir de
bijoux plus anciens
là on est face à un collier hindous qui
très probablement a été constituée à
partir de d'un ou deux bijoux indiens
qui ont été modifiés et remonter tels
que vous pouvez le voir mais vous
trichez un peu si c'est un 12 ça dépanne
musulmans tout à fait donc il est alors
la dénomination hindoue c'est celle
qu'on trouve la maison cartier l'a
enregistré comme ça dans les livres de
stocks
mais on a englobé en fait l'inde au sens
large en prenant le parti de se dire que
le lam au gol avait aussi influencer la
les bijoux traditionnels les moghols 1
était musulman tout à fait et les voilà
les fameux plumier dans des favoris tout
nageur qui sont des objets vraiment
exceptionnel et aujourd'hui ce sont les
deux seuls objets ce qui aura aussi une
peinture de cette incroyable collection
de cartier qui sont conservés sur le
territoire national tout le reste a été
dispersée beaucoup aux états unis et
dont
benoît dorémus un commentaire c'est pas
facile demande veut dire hier pour moi
des univers parallèles de de gens
passionnés moi je découvre tout
quasiment donc non non c'est comme ça ça
me semble urgent estime comme une image
il n'y aurait pas totalement le jeu
ayant longtemps travaillé dans un
magazine de mode américain donc j'étais
un peu au courant de mes jeux je dois
dire je suis assez fasciné par le
l'important je l'ignoré un peu comme un
comme toi comme vous l'importance de de
l'art islamique dans le dans le
lard de quartier quoi dans le thermique
c'est cesser une recherche qui est
complètement nouvelle
l'exposition on a avec mes collègues je
mets tout seul notamment inquiète bien
de poser mais on a travaillé pendant
quatre ans dans les archives de l'année
au départ c'est une intuition vous aviez
alors je dois dire qu'elle ait pas de
nous
l'idée de départ en fait c'est pierre
généraux qui est le directeur du style
de la maison cartier qui avait vu qu'ils
avaient vus et qui avait identifié un
lien avec les arts de l'islam est il
arrivé avec ce sujet maison voilà on
aimerait faire une exposition on vous
livre ça et on vous ouvre nos archives
et il faut dire qu'ils ont des archives
assez incroyable et donc on a plongé
pendant quatre ans dans les archives de
la maison et également dans le fond de
l'un des dessinateurs important de la
maison qui s'appelle charles jacquot qui
est conservée au musée des beaux-arts de
la ville de paris le petit palais et
grâce à ce fonds de dessins et grâce à
tout ce qu'on a découvert dans les
archives on a pu montrer prouver que
effectivement les arts de l'islam ont eu
un impact extrêmement important sur les
créations la maison cartier mais vous le
disiez sur d'autrui parce que regarder
comme ces petits flat qui sont
typiquement la syllabique quand on va
dans les palais d'al andalous en allant
d'elle en andalousie nom n'est pas les
arabes ont des frappes et effectivement
par ses répétitions qui nous sommes de
tout à fait des années 20 on a
l'impression que c'est alors voilà ça
aussi on se dit ça c'est le début du 20e
siècle en europe mais en fait non c'est
le quinzième les 14e dans le lampy rab
mais le c'est vrai qu'ils ont tellement
enfin ses formes ont été intégrés à leur
répertoire et je dois dire qu'ils les
utilisent encore aujourd'hui mais les
utiliser sans avoir la conscience de
leur origine ll était assimilé en
quelque sorte au répertoire des formes
de la maison et du coup cette exposition
a permis de d'apporter la preuve de leur
origine et aussi de de l'importance de
l'impact de cette découverte sur les
artistes parce qu'effectivement on a
complètement oublié
l'importance et l'impact de la beauté
dit sur sur l'art sur la africains
en général sur l'armée l'art du japon
aussi japon sur van gogh et ça on a
oublié ça c'est encore un champ qui
reste à défricher effectivement et la
rupture est nette avec ce qu'on appelait
l'orientalisme au 19e siècle où les
peintres à l'ehu peindre des décès de
bordel
c'était souvent l'occasion de peindre
des femmes nues la rupture est les
pannes est parce que l'orientalisme
perdure au 20e siècle par contre ce
qu'on a je pense réussi à montrer dans
l'exposition c'est qu'il ya une
émergence d'un autre courant qui va
puiser justement dans les arts de
l'islam pour pour réaliser des créations
imprégné de modernité qui vont vraiment
s'inscrire dans la modernité et ça on le
trouve dans les céramiques dans
l'illustration dans la mode et dans les
bijoux et ce courant la voilà les
graines elles sont semés au début du 20e
siècle je veux dire qu'en 1900 après à
partir de 1910 1912 avec cette mode
personne voilà c'est le monde iranien
qui va fournir des modèles des formes
des couleurs dans lesquels les artistes
vont véritablement puiser
et et c'est toute une recherche qui
reste encore à poursuivre il ya dansé
expositions environ 520 oeuvre c'est
qu'il public est ce que est ce que est
ce que le public via justement des pays
islamiques
je pense qu'on a beaucoup de français
donc on a le public régulier des arts
déco mais je pense que ils ont ils sont
étonnés de voir qu'ils ont un autre
public il ya pas mal de jeunes qui
visitent l'exposition et les chiffres
augmentent depuis l'ouverture et ça
c'est plutôt bon signe ça me fait dire
que le bouche à oreille fonctionne et
que l'éditeur sont contents et que du
coup ils parlent de l'exposition il sait
comme aussi des bars y avoir
beaucoup de communication au début ça
commence très fort et quand ça descend
mais là celle inverse justement les
chiffres augmentent et les visages les
visiteurs ont l'air
assez satisfait c'est donc au musée des
arts décoratifs à paris jusqu'au 22
février elle va se promener ensuite
cette exposition staff et elle part aux
dallas museum of art puisque c'est une
coproduction avec deux commissaires
américaine eh bien on va faire une pause
et on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
fabrice gaignault vous êtes journaliste
et écrivain la ville est plus douce est
un véritable roman d'écrivains même si
c'est un roman sur le relâchement de la
bourgeoisie comment elle est passée du
fauteuil louis saez au canapé où l'on
s'enfonce puis au pouf sur lequel on se
vautre et enfin à la moquette toulon ça
soit en tailleur avant de s'allonger de
tout son long et ce grand relâchement
s'est opérée dans tous les domaines au
fond elle a tenu le langage les moeurs
la morale l'éducation
oui on peut dire qu'on peut dire ça je
suis je suis parti j'avais envie de
ça fait longtemps que j'avais en moi
j'écris dizaine de livres mais c'est
j'avais depuis longtemps envie d'écrire
un livre qu'il soit très personnel
il n'est pas entièrement
autobiographique mais quand même
beaucoup donc c'est un j'appelle ça un
roman parce que je pense que l'écriture
et puis certains récits ont été un peu
mêlé etc mais c'est quelque chose qui
m'a qui m'a frappé en repensant à cette
époque tels que j'ai vécu dans ma
famille
de bourgeoise parisienne c'est cette
espèce de passage que vous décrivez bien
décrit au début du livre entre le entre
le siège le fauteuil et la moquette qui
a été assez preignac des formes plus bas
dit il était assez prégnant chez moi
dans ma famille et quand on repense à
cette époque c'est vrai que c'était
quelque chose qui pouvait dans certains
milieux un bourgeois ou moins pour joie
être une façon de vivre très adoptée à
l'époque mais la moquette le sol et vous
êtes devenu un spécialiste des années
60-70 votre enfance
votre jeunesse au fond 1 vous êtes né en
1956 et ceux des banques vous la
revisite vous avez revisité dans
plusieurs de vos livres
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
spécialisation récente de revenir en
arrière comme ça de revisiter une époque
si on prend balzac quand on lit les
romans de balzac qui fait pas la
différence entre le règne de charles 10
de louis philippe et de napoléon iii il
a connu les deux ses romans
100 en sont un forcément inspiré mais il
n'a il ne s'arrête pas là dessus il
écrit pour l'éternité au fond j'ai
l'impression que les écrivains
aujourd'hui veulent absolument alors
est-ce que c'est l'influencé d'internet
on se documente plus facilement mais
vous vous les avez véritablement vécu
ces époques là oui on est emmené en 1956
où les ai vraiment vécu aussi bien ses
75 années 70 internet à moi c'est ma vie
je peux y voilà exactement mais je me
dis pourquoi est-ce qu'on assiste à ce
besoin quand vous me parlez du
relâchement de la bourgeoisie je pense
que on le ressent encore aujourd'hui
mais voulant créer dans ce moment qui a
été un véritablement une transition oui
alors j'ai écrit quand même un premier
roman qui était très actuel mais qui est
beaucoup moins de succès qui s'appelle
l'eau noire et qui était complètement
kate et contemporain mais il est vrai
que lorsqu'on parle de moi je ne suis
pas du tout connu sais pas ce que je
vais dire mais on parle toujours de moi
comme l'auteur dé gérer sixties par
exemple ces deux livres qui qui reste
plus de moi ok on connaît il ya des
tentatives d'adaptation enfin voila
c'est un livre qui est pas mal circulé
et je n'y avais déjà un chapitre dans ce
livre consacré à ma mère et je me creuse
oui je je suis absolument fasciné par
cette époque qui m'a vu grandir est ce
qu'il y avait à la fois chez moi une
enfance heureuse mais qui était un peu
détruites par des années de pensions qui
ont été terribles c'était une tension
extrêmement sévère tout en étant élevé
par des parents très très libéraux un
saignement qu'on puisse dire donc il
cette rupture un peu cette schizophrénie
dont je parle entre le la pension
catholique avec encore des châtiments
corporels qui a disparu après 68 ou en
70 et le léthé assez relâché à saint
tropez puisque je connais c'est à la
fois c'est donc je connaissais à la fois
de la communion la confection toutes les
semaines et à saint tropez où je voyais
ma mère les amis de ma mère qui avait
les seins nus donc c'était un monde pour
moi qui ne cesse de me fasciner entre la
entre la passion musicale dont on
parlait avec benoît et d'autres domaines
qui est victime qui m'intéresse beaucoup
et puis l'horreur d'une autre façon
quelque chose qui a disparu
et je voulais dire vous accueillant le
russe tout à l'heure pour moi c'est un
peu le petit chose qui était déjà un
roman autobiographique d'alphonse allais
dans la femme du 10 de halak d'alphonse
daudet pardon est la fin du 19e et mais
là ce serait le petit chose dans sa
version sixties est plutôt seventies
donne sexy des seventies oui mais cette
petite chose pour moi et le petit chose
c'est pareil ils faisaient pas attention
à l'époque le petit chose c'était censé
pouvoir être lus à n'importe quelle
époque sans jamais de référence à une
époque précise
j'espère que ce seront peut-être aussi
lui comme quelque chose d'universel sur
l'art a toujours inscrit dans une épave
et c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
pourquoi se spécialise dans des époques
aujourd'hui pourquoi on ne veut plus
écrire le livre vous auriez pu raconter
la même histoire sans insister sur les
acteurs les
les tout ce qui date au fond on aime que
nos romans date aujourd'hui
c'est une petite critique au kun en
outre et non pas parce qu'ils sont que
c'est très très bien fait là et que chez
vous c'est justifié mais je me demande
toujours pourquoi aurait on se crée
cette complication au fond oui oui c'est
vrai alors est-ce que je ne sais pas je
portais ce livre en moi depuis très
longtemps des proches me poussait à
l'écrire parce qu'ils connaissaient
aussi le land vert du décor c'est à dire
derrière les fastes d'une certaine
bourgeoisie du 7e arrondissement od d
une adolescence une enfance et une
adolescence qui avait été assez
compliqué quand même oui plus malheureux
alors on s'aperçoit qu'on peut être on
se dit oh là là quelle chance il a dû
avoir pas du tout non et je joue et je
trouve sept jours crétins les gens qui
pensent que le qui a une prime aux
malheurs spécialement dans un milieu
social etc c'est quelque chose lorsqu'on
est enfant l'enfant peut se construire
adultes on est libre de ça mais
lorsqu'on est enfant je pense que c'est
quelque chose hélas la mieux partagée du
monde après il ya des mémés pour revenir
à ça je trouvais en plus c'était une
époque romanesque que je trouve très
intéressante parce qu'il ya une
libération des moeurs exemple dont on
bénéficie toujours qui est par ailleurs
qui est par ailleurs très
bonne qui a été très bonne mais d'un
autre côté il y avait ce que j'analyse
est que le temps quelque chose
d'horrible un peu dans le une
politisation extrême
d'amis de gens que je connaissais qui
était ma is to kick qui qui voulait que
j'adhère aux parties de polpot qu'en
même temps il y avait tous les gens qui
prenaient beaucoup de drogue il y avait
un côté monstrueux en même temps c'est
ça que ça veut dire
l'espé autobiographique vous dit à la
fois c'est à un roman autobiographique
et c'est pas un roman autobiographique
j'imagine que vous avez dû recommencer
certaines choses néanmoins on se dit
quand on lit que c'est forcément
autobiographique donc c'est
particulièrement réussie dans ce domaine
ça doit pas être rien de tout déballer
vous peut parler de l'auto destruction
de votre mère
vous parlez de votre père vous parlez de
vous de vos frères et soeurs
c'est pas rien qua non la partie la plus
difficile pour moi peut-être je n'ai pas
de si vous en êtes rendu compte c'est de
parler de moi aussi par forcément bien
c'est ça un livre intéressant j'ai été
longtemps critique littéraire je le suis
toujours
c'est quand même les livres qui met en
danger l'auteur quoi je sais c'est pas
je me contente pas de me plaindre et je
me plains pas d'ailleurs puisque j'ai un
côté un peu indifférent tout ce qui
m'arrive et je je je voulais aussi
montrer que j'étais assez faible un
petit peu la chanteuse des militaires un
peu un peu mou cette époque-là ouvriers
touchent mais ça fait partie du vrai
roman autobiographique voit le roman
d'apprentissage utilise est un roman
que j'ai
pas facile non c'est pas facile de
déballer de ses secrets au fond non non
et d'ailleurs on m'a demandé on m'a
demandé si j'avais fait une psychanalyse
avant une journée d'essai j'ai passé
deux psychologues juste après l'avoir lu
je me suis dit mais pourquoi êtes-vous
devenu journaliste mais si vous n y
étais une fille vous auriez sûrement
fait psy
parce que quand on a vécu dans une
famille comme celle ci en général les
filles elles deviennent psy il est la
clé à la fin du lit elles veulent
réparer les garçons m'ont préparé du
tout non non je jeu il ya une des clés à
la fin du livre fête un moment je
voulais devenir on m'a proposé je sais
pas trop quoi faire après la ponction
j'étais tellement dégoûté par la pension
que lorsque j'ai atterri dans le monde à
17 ans j'ai je me suis dit j'aimais
beaucoup lire un jeu disait beaucoup
j'écrivais un peu je me suis dit bon je
vais peut être essayer d'être juriste
j'ai failli être le secrétaire
particulier de voiliers se passe
toujours
de guider car que je cite sous un autre
nom il son fils était à chier votre
place ya patronat il avait des gens des
secrétaires particuliers c'était
l'époque où ce malade et en bentley qui
venait chez mes grands parents mes
oncles et puis finalement ça mais a
tenté et c c'est vraiment pour ne pas le
citer au dans une boîte qui s'appelait
le privilège
une journaliste beaucoup plus âgée que
moi m'a dit mais tu devrais
je t'aime bien viens viens de voir ça
s'est vraiment passé comme ça je pensais
que j'avais parfois on dit qu il ya un
débouché on dit un artiste aussi parce
qu'on sait rien faire d'autre sam est
peut-être arrivé j'ai mes écrits votre
votre personnage vous
est constamment déprimé dans ce livre 11
il a vraiment eu une jeunesse
malheureusement
j'ai eu une enfance très heureuse mais
peut-être pas ce qu'il m'arrivait rien
et j'ai dû me venger par la suite vous
arrive plein de choses oui mais alors
dès que je débarque chez mes grands
parents dès que adrien débarque chez ses
grands parents à saint tropez tout ça
c'est quand même l'été c'est ça reste
des moments d'émerveillement pour moi et
aussi les périodes où
chez les grands parents que ce soit du
côté paternel ou maternel y avait quand
même des grands moments mais c'est vrai
qu'entre la tension qui était vraiment
lugubre et à l'époque c'était l'enfer à
aujourd'hui les enfants veulent se
débarrasser de leurs parents ils partent
en internat à l'époque c'était les
parents qui n'ont pas rassuré enfants
dans des endroits épouvantable
alors à décharge c'est vrai que nous
sommes enfin la famille rentré d'algérie
et qu'il absolue c'était pas ce n'était
pas pratique et il y avait plusieurs
enfants donc voilà la pension
correspondait peut-être un quand on
avait quelques moyens assurer une
éducation peut-être une éducation une
rigueur lorsque tout commençait à
le camp c'est je fus tirs dans un autre
milieu parce qu'il y avait aussi c'est
un milieu moi je parle d'un milieu que
je connais d'adultes qui passait
beaucoup de temps chez castel quand même
c 'est je veux dire je sais pas je
voulais pas citer des boîtes où
étiez-vous le site un bon d'accord les
sujets bien dire le souterrain par les
deux parce qu'il est beaucoup dire sur
le palace et sabine erreur un peu voler
un peu et c'est quelque chose que oui
effectivement où il y avait
il y avait ce côté où on ça partait pas
d'un mauvais principe on se disait qu'on
allait mettre
les enfants en pension comme ça il
serait préservée de ski mais le problème
c'est que les parents ne mesurait pas
parfois ce qu'à l'époque on pouvait pas
évidemment
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs le personnage fait
une chute à 12 ans qui est
favorite à commettre et tous chez terra
les parents le retrouver mais menacé
d'une tension encore plus sévère et à
l'époque c'est vrai qu'on ne
manifestaient pas on ne disait pas je
vais me plaindre auprès du juge ou pire
on croyait pas tellement les enfants
faisait que c'est comme ça et c'est
d'abord faire mais la pension c'est
forcément religieuses nous pensons
religieuse pas ou pas du tout la plupart
des pensions était la mienne était très
religieuse mais
c'est là où je reviens au début ce
relâchement à la fois dans les tenues
que vous que vous décrivez en détail
avec le passage du fauteuil louis saez à
la moquette mais aussi dans tout le
reste c'est à partir de ce moment là on
fasse a dû commencer chez certains
moyenne avant mai mais on voit bien
qu'il ya un relâchement et aujourd'hui
les enfants parlent si mal c'est parce
que leurs parents nous ont leur âme
d'aller parler
mais les parents parler bien encore les
grands parents
il ya quelque chose qui m'avait frappé
par exemple étant entendu que c'est vrai
que la première fois que j'ai rencontré
un personnage que j'appelle une sorte
d'olibrius qui était un peintre raté
maoïstes et qui m'a parlé de foucauld
moi je pensais que c'était le père de
foucauld tous les week-ends toute la
semaine on parlait du père de foucauld
que pour lequel j'avais pas du tout de
l'antipathie que je trouvais un
personnage très intéressant c'est pour
vous dire à l'époque il y avait deux
foucault en fait qui m'a lancé dans ma
tête qui pourquoi ce titre ces sorties
de la phrase d'un de mes grands pères
qui concerne allait pas que j'allais
enfin je voyais il était toujours la vie
la plus douce c'est de ne penser à rien
et c'est une phrase qu'il avait trouvé
dans montaigne et après quand j'ai pensé
à ce titre donc je cite j'ai vu que
c'était montaigne on le sait reprenait
beaucoup et ça vient de sophocle ça
vient de sauver je trouvais que c'était
une phrase qui résumait bien oui mais il
ya aussi le côté je pense que c'est vous
vraiment sur la photo oui
et c'est vrai aussi qu'il ya toute cette
idée de douceur qui est lié au jet de 60
et depuis la douceur de vivre la dolce
vita de fellini est en fait à chaque
fois ça montre une ça montre une
décadence l'idée douceur et
libéré et 60 est liée à la décadence
chez nous oui donc ça peut-être que j'ai
voulu rencontre aller le personnel fasse
voir mario adore ce qui est un acteur
très connu à l'époque la guitare
italiens tels liens allemand d'origine
mais qui paie des voies larges et dans
le cinéma et dans lequel le héros va qui
est un peu mon double va habiter
quelques temps à rome il est à la
recherche aussi inconsciemment de cette
évita parce que mario adorf lui présente
des personnages déjà qu'ils se trompent
ou moins week sont toujours célèbre mais
qui ont connu la et faste des années 50
il est fasciné par ça parce qu adrien
ses parents sont assez proches de mon
bien connu brigitte bardot bardot je
trouve qu'il ya un portrait de saint
tropez qui est vraiment réussi et je
n'ai pas connu saint tropez cette époque
là mais je trouve de cresson la façon
dont on va de décrire saint tropez
tellement faux ce que je vous avais dit
qu'aucun romand sur saint-tropez
pratiquement mais parce que tout élève
tout est lamentable ce ne sont que des
enfilades de clichés
et c'était un mélange en fait y avait
des artistes y avait des gens je parle
de ça me ferait tous ces gens là qui qui
était aussi là bas c'était une époque
aussi oui oui c'est pas que les bikini
sur la plage c'était j'aimais bien
décrire tout ces gens qui gravitaient
autour de mes parents tous les
journalistes de match qui ont disparu
tous ces gens qui étaient tous les
copains on appelait ça des copains à
l'époque c'était un score des packs de
batteries oui c'est bien ça vient de
sortir de chez grasset la ville est plus
douce c'est signé fabrice gaignault
[Musique]
benoît doremus vous pratiquez vous aussi
le taux biographie mais chanter dans
tous vos albums vous donner de vos
nouvelles et dans le cinquième qui vient
de sortir désolé pour les fantômes il ya
une chanson assez gonflé assez
courageuse aussi parce que vous y
regarder la vérité en face en effet
depuis quinze ans que vous chantez vous
n'avez toujours pas percé en dépit de
tous les encouragements reçus de renous
de francis cabrel en particulier mais
vous êtes toujours là et en fait c'est
ce que vous racontez dans une chanson
qui s'intitule on croit en moi je
propose de la regarder
[Musique]
ça fait 15 ans que je vis de mon sac ça
fait 15 ans que je vis de mon art quinze
ans que je tiens la north ça fait 15 ans
que je tiens là bas pour venir à vous je
navigue à vue je n'ai pas la nostalgie
de mes débuts je dis non non quand on me
demande si j'ai disparu je dis oui quand
on me demande si je connus sur les
photos j'ai l'air d'un gamin renault
benito copain copain j'ai le même amour
pour la chanson justin l'excès sur
l'inflation dictionnaire de rimes de
synonymes mon grand robert ma petite
routine je mets des synapses en
compétition à fond les yeux au plafond
si j'étais assis chance que tu m'aurais
déjà vu mais si ge est si mauvais
j'aurais pas tenu ça fait si longtemps
j'ai même plus d'angoissé je les ai
placé tellement de temps passe benito
bientôt un nouvel album benito continue
il faut il faut lé plus si légère ma
guitare en bois ça fait 15 ans
en moi
on croit
tu crois
[Musique]
à force de tenir la pancarte j'ai une
petite hernie discale mon rêve de gosse
dans l'est par intermittence et
traitement local tout seul à l'hôtel
tout seul dans le train je commence à
râler tellement je me plains je
m'engueule avec ma chanson française
mais le soir
et même si a pas toujours foule il ya
toujours une rencontre un peu cool et à
ce que je suis content de revoir ya
toute une histoire il ya que j'ai pu
toucher des gens comme henri death mon
coeur d'enfant comme reggiani mais dix
sept ans et comme gainsbourg mes
sentiments 15 ans quand même bien qu'on
soutient je suis déjà maigres revenus de
loin requinqué d'amour participative et
août une tournée avec francis j'suis
allé chanter l'amoureux transi en
indépendant en tachycardie j'ai appris
et puis j'ai encore appris j'ai laissé
des plumes aussi
mais en croix
[Musique]
tu crois en moi
beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus beaucoup
d'apple est trop peu lui même si le
passé paul eu des regrets aucun aucun
beaucoup d'ego d'où les dégâts beaucoup
rigolé en tout cas 15 ans de vaan à
réaction d'attenté d'allitérations et
jorane depuis si longtemps j'ai des
chansons en noir et blanc et maxime a
fait une musique et à l'art plus petite
fille si je repasse l'accent sur mon bep
et y aura jamais de plan b et je regarde
dans la glace mon rêve
ça fait 15 ans que je vis mon sac ça
fait 15 ans que je vis de mon art alors
or alors
vacciner ou pas je repars
pour venir à vous je navigue à vue je
n'ai pas la nostalgie de mes débuts je
dis non non quand on me demande si j'ai
disparu je dis oui quand on demande 10
juin au mieux
croire en moi
tu crois en moi
c'est formidable
il fallait quand même c'est assez unique
d'être aussi sincère dans une situation
qui est pas forcément à votre avantage
j'ai toujours fait ça donc depuis mes
débuts de 15 ans de raconter l'envers du
décor ma petite vie de chanteur à la
première personne sur une ou deux
chansons dans un disque un jeu pas que
ça mais je vais toujours faire est
connecté quand ça m'a plutôt souri quand
renault a produit mon premier album
quand même arriver des choix de choses
et puis et puis voilà je me bats c'était
logique pour moi de continuer en
essayant d'être un peu un peu
transparent 1 on peut se dire on peut se
demander à qui vous adressez vous
pourriez femme mère mais vous adresser
aussi à tous ceux qui ont financé
l'album c'est un peu ça parce que je
suis dans un entre-deux bizarre en fait
effectivement j'ai un super flic un
public qui me suit depuis mes débuts et
qui en plus de me suivre à financer cet
album via un financement participatif et
le précédent il ya cinq ans et à la
foire le grand public ne me connaît pas
et à la fois j'ai quand même des
parrains super prestigieux renault
francis cabrel parmi d'autres maxime le
forestier qui m'ont soutenue encouragée
et aidée
donc je suis dans une situation un peu
bizarre moi vous l'avez rappelé que je
vous invitais dans trois émissions
différents absolument donc je suis parti
six très concrètes à cet échec
mais ce n'est pas vraiment un échec
c'est cette situation est bizarre c'est
que j'ai une super reconnaisant ont tout
le monde rêverait j'ai passé une semaine
à travailler mes chansons avec francis
cabrel c'est le rêve de tout aux auteurs
compositeurs comme l'écriture comme les
textes j'ai une relation professionnelle
et amicale avec renault ford je peux
absolument pas me plaindre et à la fois
je rame c'est très concret je gagne à
peine ma vie avec la musique est à la
fois des gens me suivent même beaucoup
bon voilà cette chanson résumé un petit
peu à peu près couvert tout le spectre
oui puis c'est une chanson pour dire que
c'est un métier impossible à arrêter en
fait parce que même des moments de
découragement qui sont qui sont
fréquents
je me suis demandée en plus avec ce qui
nous tombe depuis sur la tête depuis
deux ans est-ce que vous faire changer
trouver autre chose et je trouve pas
c'est un sénat c'est une drôle
d'attirant je suis quand même est monté
par cette cette passion de l'écriture de
la chanson c'est un métier qu impossible
à arrêter et donc mais ça que j'ai des
doutes quand vous dites que c'est
impossible à arrêter je n'ai jamais eu
envie de raccrocher si un moment mais
leur vie c'est à cet égard du rebond ils
veulent pas de moi ils veulent pas de
moi quoi bon alors on veut de moi et on
veut pas de moi j'ai eu deux albums en
maisons de disques en major encore une
fois j'ai des artistes très talentueux
qui sinon qu'ils signent pas en maison
de disques et malgré leurs efforts et
malgré tout leur temps à moi j'ai eu
quand même eu cette chance je veux pas
faire que comme plein de mai
mais les radios diffusent pas non plus
très très peu mes chansons apf un mail
envie d'arrêter si si je l'eus un
serment et est très fort et puis et
surtout il ya eu un moment où j'arrivais
peut écrire où j'écris une dizaine de
chansons qui étaient n'était pas bien
quoi que et donc je me suis dit bon bah
si j'en ai un petit peu marre et si en
plus ces nouvelles chansons sont pas
bien ok belge alors c'est une période
qui dure quelques mois et puis et puis
pouf on retrouvera un jour un dossier
dans l'ordinateur on relit un brouillon
mais en fait c'était pas mal faut
peut-être que j'y aille au bout de celle
là puis on y passe quelques heures et
puis bon bah ça fait deux chansons
terminer puis on les essais sur scène à
puis on en parle est purement voit un
petit message et puis on me demande
quand je sors un nouvel album c'est pour
ça que j'ai que c'est impossible à
arrêter c'est qu'il ya la passion de
l'écriture israël avec soi être aussi
parce qu'on est à une époque où on est
en lien avec ces avec ses supporters
autrefois ça va arriver pas y avait pas
les réseaux sociaux il n'y avait pas une
communication directe après c'est par
une maison de disques on écrivait au
chanteur moi j'ai un peu connu cette
transition moi j'ai mon premier album
c'est 2006-2007 et les réseaux sociaux
étaient naissance était myspace à
l'époque sa part est un dinosaure donc
j'ai pas connu vraiment l'avant j'ai
connu de cette période un peu
transitoire mais maintenant les réseaux
sociaux sont omniprésents mais c'est ça
qui m'a poussé à me lancer dans
l'aventuré d'un nouvel album celui là
c'est que au lieu de me demander
quand est-ce que tu sors un album dans
les nouvelles que je recevais c'était
quand est-ce que tu refais un
financement participatif et j'en avais
un bon souvenir il était content d'avoir
aider concrètement un artiste et voilà
et un message de messagerie messages et
puis je me suis dit il ya des gens qui
attendaient les chansons sont prêtes
alors oui le chemin est un peu plus
complet vous avez l'air de dire dans
cette chanson ça fait 15 ans que je vis
de mon art on peut vraiment vivre sans
vendre beaucoup de disques et alors que
les salles sont souvent pas pleines
comme vous le dis tout est alors oui on
en janvier jean vit chichement mais jean
vit tranquillement je vis à paris et je
dois payer mon loyer donc encore une
fois ça va mais mais j'ai envie pas
comment on vivait quand comment vivre
certaines vedettes mais oui c'est moi
c'est les concerts me font vivre oui oui
oui on est dans un beau pays on à
l'intermittence du spectacle n'est ce
pas moi je suis très reconnaissant de ça
la sacem nos soutiens on a un peu de
droits d'auteur enfin voilà qu quand on
bosse dur est contre nous et qu'on
s'accroche on en vit en france en tout
cas je crois qu'à des pays où c'est plus
compliqué je crois que les en angleterre
où il ya passé statut là un peu un peu
près un peu protecteur c'est plus
difficile même quand on a du succès de
dans vivre convenablement alors est ce
que vous vous interrogez en vous disant
ou est-ce que j'ai pas fait ce qu'il
fallait faire ou où j'ai pas eu de
chance à un moment c'était à deux doigts
voilà on est obligé de se poser la
question aux attentes comme vous on peut
refaire un petit peu le film quelques
fois mais à chaque fois que je refaire
le film jeu très vite ça s'équilibre pas
ce que je fais la liste des choses
géniales qui me sont arrivés encore une
fois renault à chanter une de mes
chansons enfin je peux vous raconter des
choses comme ça qui sont des gars nous
de la vie au nom luce vous prend
premières pages et
francis cabrel aussi c'est ça et puis
j'ai une reconnaissance dans le métier
dans le métier dans le petit milieu
qu'en fait que la chanson donc on est
mon nom puis on aime bien je pense que
tu laisses et des bons souvenirs à
droite à gauche et puis j'ai des bons
copains donc quand on fait un film si
c'est difficile et puis sans vouloir non
regretté non parce que quand j'écris
je bosse dur ça c'est la moindre des
choses mais j'y passe un temps fou et ça
peut pas laisser de place aux regrets de
bosser tout simplement et de ne rien
lâcher et puis d'être traversé la france
avec ma guitare c'est ça qui me pousse à
continuer aussi c'est le fait de ne pas
avoir de regrets justement bon et puis
il ya tous les exemples aussi de tous
ceux qui alors dans la chanson ou au
cinéma ou d'un dut ou dans les
littératures ce qui était insuffisant
pour la cdc le dernier j'arrête après
celui là si ça marche pas et puis paf ça
marche
il ya plage pourrait vous faire une
liste à vraisemblable dur plus avec vous
dans les faux adieux je me méfiais je me
méfie de moi même aussi parce qu'il ya
cinq ans je pensais justement que j'y
retournerais pas et la meuf me revoici
donc là je me fais cette promesse à moi
ne faut pas croire que ça reviendra
jamais en fait ça revient les gens que
j'en parlais justement des artistes
prestigieux maxime le forestier il ya
deux trois ans quand je lisais que
j'arrivais pu écrire que ça sorte f1 que
c'était que c'était laborieux nous
racontait que nos bars numéro claude
nougaro appeler ça la torture sublime et
voulez dire que vous n'y retourne quand
même même si ça fait mal et je me suis
rendu compte que cette douleur dans la
création elle est commune à tout le
monde en fait riche palette plus au fait
que le fait de percer enfin percé être
enfin regarder pour ce que l'on est
et ça peut venir à n'importe quel moment
mais tardivement par saleh est souvent
un moment où on croyait que j'étais fini
quoi c'est possible peut-être c'est
comme l'amour c'est quand on s'y attend
le moins que ça vous tombe dessus
franchement je ne sais pas je crois pas
non plus moi je fais un art justement
dont on parlera probablement pas dans
600 ans c'est un peu un art de
l'instantané la chanson c'est des
chansons
qu'il avait créée à l'époque je suis pas
sûr que le succès arrive à 60 ans non
plus mais mais peut-être que ce sera
peut-être que ce sera la chanson écrite
pour quelqu'un d'autre qui me permettra
de continuer ce que j'aime aussi ça
écrire pour les autres alors c'est un
métier riche quand même c'est pas que
être auteur compositeur avec sa guitare
sur scène c'est un métier large et est
riche et donc voilà il ya plusieurs
choses à faire désolé pour les fantômes
c'est le titre du cinquième album
merci encore merci tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]